Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. What is the Chinese war like? Well, at least I know it isn't like wars in history books.
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告畅听、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢您收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告畅听并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您正在使用苹果播客应用程序，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。中国的战争是怎样的？至少我知道它与历史书上的战争不同。
You know, those lucid, tidy maps of battles one used to study at school. The flanks like neat little cubes, the pincer movements working with mathematical precision, the reinforcements never failing to arrive. It isn't like that at all. War is bombing an already disused arsenal, missing it and killing a few old women. War is lying in a stable with a gangrenous leg. War is drinking hot water in a barn and worrying about one's wife. War is a handful of lost and terrified men in the mountains shooting at something moving in the undergrowth. War is waiting for days with nothing to do, shouting down a dead telephone, going without sleep or sex or a wash. War is untidy, inefficient, obscure, and largely a matter of chance.
你知道的，那些人们过去在学校里研究过的清晰、整洁的战役地图。侧翼就像整齐的小方块，钳形攻势以数学般精准的方式运作，增援部队总能及时赶到。情况根本不是这样的。战争是轰炸一个本已废弃的军火库，却炸偏了并炸死了几个老妇人。战争是带着一条坏疽的腿躺在马歇尔的马厩里。战争是在谷仓里喝着热水，为妻子担心。战争是山里一小群迷失方向、惊恐万分的男子，朝着灌木丛中移动的东西开枪。战争是无所事事地等待好几天，冲着打不通的电话大喊大叫，没觉睡、没爱做、没澡洗。战争是杂乱无章的、低效的、晦涩难明的，而且在很大程度上纯属偶然。
So Tom, that was W.H. Auden, the great poet. And he was talking on the BBC in January 1939, having come back from China, about his experience of the Second World War in China, which of course had not started yet, according to the traditional chronology, because we think of World War II beginning in 1939. But it didn't, if you're in East Asia, did it? It absolutely did not. And the war between Japan and China, which breaks out in 1937. Well, or 1931. Well, we will have the chance to test that, but let's call it 1937 for now. Is it a kind of hideous prelude to the Second World War, or is it the opening stages of the Second World War? I mean, this horrendous conflict, which is so little known in the West, and yet it's so influential, not just on the course of the Second World War, but also, of course, on Chinese history right the way up to the present day, and therefore on the entire world. Yeah, on the entire world.
所以，汤姆，那是 W·H·奥登，伟大的诗人。他在 1939 年 1 月通过 BBC 谈论了他从中国归来后的经历，谈到了他在中国的第二次世界大战的经历——当然，按照传统的年代学，这场战争当时还没有开始，因为我们认为二战始于 1939 年。但如果你身处东亚，事实并非如此，对吗？绝对不是。日本和中国之间的战争在 1937 年爆发。好吧，或者 1931 年。好吧，我们有机会来检验这一点，但我们暂时称之为 1937 年。这是第二次世界大战的一种可怕的前奏，还是第二次世界大战的开端？我的意思是，这场在西方鲜为人知、却又如此具有影响力的可怕冲突，不仅对二战的进程，而且当然也对直至现今的中国历史，乃至对整个世界，都产生了深远的影响。是的，对整个世界。
I mean, Tom, also, 14 million people died, colossal numbers of refugees, perhaps 80, 100 million refugees. I mean, this is not the weird thing is you and I were probably brought up to think of this as a sideshow, weren't we? You know, it was sort of in a 20 chapter book on the Second World War. There was one chapter called The War in the East. Yeah. But China is the first country to face a kind of Axis power onslaught. So there is really only one person to talk about this. And that is Rana Mitter, who regular listeners will remember from the absolute tour de force he gave on the Cultural Revolution a few months back. And he has written an extraordinary, brilliant, and I have to say, grueling book, because the subject is grueling. China's War with Japan, 1937 to 1945, The Struggle for Survival. And Rana,
我的意思是，汤姆，还有 1400 万人死亡，数量惊人的难民，也许有 8000 万到 1 亿难民。我的意思是，奇怪的是，你和我大概都是被灌输了这样一种观念，把它当成一场微不足道的插曲，对吧？你知道的，在关于第二次世界大战的 20 章书中，其中有一章叫做《东方战争》。是的。但中国是第一个面临轴心国猛烈攻势的国家。所以，关于这个话题，真的只有一个人选可以交谈。那就是拉纳·米特（Rana Mitter），经常收听节目的听众会记得他几个月前关于文化大革命的绝对精彩绝伦的演讲。他写了一本非凡、精彩、而且我必须说令人精疲力竭的书，因为这个主题本身就很折磨人。《中国的对日战争，1937-1945：生存之战》。拉纳，
welcome back. So good to have you back. And I guess that subtitle, 1937 to 1945, you're making a statement then about when the Second World War begins, or are you? I am, Tom. It's great to be back back and Dominic, great to be back as well. And I do want to make the case in the book. In fact, I think I use the sentence at the end of the first chapter when basically the first shots are fired in a little village just outside Beijing, which is still there today. It's a place called Wanping and I've been there quite a few times. It now has a big museum of the war placed right there. But the last line of the chapter is, although nobody involved knew it, the Second World War had just begun.
欢迎回来。很高兴你能回来。我想副标题是“1937年至1945年”，你这是在就第二次世界大战何时开始表态，还是说并非如此？汤姆，是的。很高兴回来，多米尼克，也很高兴回来。我确实想在书中阐明这个观点。事实上，我想我在第一章的结尾用过这样一句话：当时在北京郊外的一个小村庄里打响了第一枪，那个地方今天依然存在。那个地方叫宛平，我去过好几次。现在那里有一个大型的抗战纪念馆。但这一章的最后一句话是：尽管身处其中的人当时并不知道，但第二次世界大战刚刚开始。
And I think that this is the way to think about this particular theater of war. It is, of course, as it's sometimes known, the Sino-Japanese War, a war between the Chinese and Japanese. And at the beginning, Dominic gave us some of the amazing, horrifying statistics that are involved with this bloodshed that took place over these eight years. But I think it's also important to note that we have to pull the Asian war back into the idea of the global war. And we might spend a moment or two, why don't we, just working out whether or not that idea of 1937 as a start point can be logically maintained? Because this would be my argument as to why we think this should, well, I think this should be the beginning of World War II. The war, in a sense, becomes genuinely global. In 1941, you have Barbarossa, the invasion of the Soviet Union by the Nazis. You have then Pearl Harbor, of course, in December. And that's when Americans in particular, hello to any of our American listeners, you know, tend to think the war becomes global because, of course, the United States becomes involved against Japan. Until that
我认为这就是思考这个特定战区的方式。这当然就是有时所谓的抗日战争，即中国人和日本人之间的一战。在开始的时候，多米尼克给我们列举了一些惊人的、可怕的统计数字，这些数字与这八年里发生的流血事件有关。但我认为同样重要的是要注意，我们必须把亚洲战争重新纳入全球战争的理念中。我们不妨花上一两分钟，探讨一下 1937 年作为起点这一观点是否在逻辑上能够站得住脚？因为这就是我为什么认为这应该是——好吧，我认为这应该是第二次世界大战的开端的理由。在某种程度上，这场战争真正演变成了全球性的。1941 年，你有了“巴巴罗萨”行动，纳粹对苏联的入侵。当然，同年 12 月又发生了珍珠港事件。正是在那个时候，尤其是美国人们——向我们所有的美国听众问好——往往认为战争变成了全球性的，因为美国当然卷入了对日战争。直到那个
point, there's an argument that you have basically a vicious war in Europe, which is being fought by the Nazis against other major powers, the French and the British. And of course, their empires are involved. Really, it's a continental war at its heart. But if that is the beginning of World War Two, as we tend to think of 3rd of September 1939, to put W.H. Auden back into the discussion again, in that case, why not 7th of July 1937, which is when locally garrisoned Japanese troops and local Chinese troops start firing at each other in a small incident, Sarajevo, like you might say. I don't think anyone at that point knew that they were starting a continental war. And then it blows up for reasons I suspect we'll
时间点，有一种观点认为，你基本上是在欧洲爆发了一场残酷的战争，由纳粹与法国和英国等主要大国交战。当然，他们的帝国也卷入了其中。本质上，这是一场核心位于欧洲大陆的战争。但如果那是第二次世界大战的开端，就像我们倾向于认为的 1939 年 9 月 3 日那样——再次把 W·H·奥登带入讨论中——那么，为什么不能是 1937 年 7 月 7 日呢？当时，驻扎在当地的日本军队和中国地方军队在一场小摩擦中开始交火，可以说就像萨拉热窝事件一样。我认为当时没有任何人知道他们正在挑起一场大陆战争。然后，由于我猜我们会去探究的原因，它爆发成了
explore into essentially a massive titanic conflict between two nations, between China and Japan, which then gets absorbed just like the war, into a global war that ends only with ashes and destruction in 1945. So that's my case for 1937. So Rana, can we pull it right back even further? Because this is a conflict that in your book, you trace the roots of this back to the 19th century. So the shock of westernization hitting, I guess, China. Westernization hits Japan. So Japan feels it has to modernize and keep up. But China, there's a tremendous sense of fragmentation and humiliation and so on with the sort of depredations of Western colonialists.
本质上是两个国家之间一场巨大而震撼的冲突，即中日两国之间的冲突，随后就像那场战争一样被卷入了一场全球战争，最终在 1945 年以灰烬和毁灭告终。这就是我支持 1937 年的理由。那么，拉纳，我们能把时间再往回推溯吗？因为在你的书中，这场冲突的根源可以追溯到 19世纪。也就是西方化冲击波及到中国的时刻。西方化冲击了日本。因此日本觉得必须现代化并跟上步伐。但中国则伴随着西方殖民者的掠夺，产生了一种巨大的破碎感和屈辱感等等。
And then there's this horrendous civil war in the sort of second half of the 19th century, the Taiping Rebellion, as we call it. So China, which has been, for most of human history, recorded history, this tremendous sort of hegemon, I suppose, is it fair to call it a basket case in the end of the 19th century? It's not a basket case, but it's a very troubled state indeed. I mean, Dominic, essentially, I think one way we can think about that whole sweep, perhaps from the mid 19th century to the mid 20th century in East Asia is that it is a clash of two ideologies, each one of which sums up something very fundamental about each of the countries. So on the Asian mainland in China, you have the growth of one ideology, which is Chinese nationalism. China at that point is a country that in the 1830s is hit by an assault from forces that it had never really encountered before. The might of the industrialized West, you know, it's a couple of decades after the
然后是 19世纪下半叶那场可怕的内战，也就是我们所说的太平天国运动。因此，在人类历史、有文字记载的历史的大部分时间里一直扮演着这种巨大的霸权角色的中国，在 19世纪末期被称为一个烂摊子，这公平吗？它不是一个烂摊子，但确实是一个饱受困扰的国家。多米尼克，从根本上说，我认为看待东亚从 19世纪中期到 20世纪中期这一宏大历史进程的一个方法是，它是两种意识形态的冲突，每一种意识形态都概括了各自国家的一些极其根本的东西。因此，在亚洲大陆的中国，你看到了某一种意识形态的发展，那就是中国民族主义。当时的中国在 1830 年代遭受了从未真正遇到过的势力的攻击。工业化西方的力量，你知道的，那是在
Napoleonic Wars have ended. It's an era when industrialization has turned Britain, France, other countries towards this much stronger sense, not only of becoming industrially capable, but also building empires of their own. And they're looking south, they're looking east Opium Wars. In other words, the Western world, first the British, but then others, including the French, come along and basically force open the doors of China's Qing dynasty, the dynasty which had been on the throne since the late 17th century, 1644. Very much, as you said, a dynasty which, like Chinese dynasties before it, had seen itself as being at the heart of civilization, the heart of the world. And suddenly these foreigners, these figures from outside, come along with their big ironclad ships. Barbarians. I'm always slightly wary about the term Yi being translated as barbarians, though it's a good shorthand. It certainly involves a certain kind of amused contempt about it, but we sometimes put
拿破仑战争结束几十年后。这是一个工业化使英国、法国和其他国家转向更强烈意识的时代，不仅要在工业上具备能力，还要建立自己的帝国。他们把目光投向南方，投向东方——鸦片战争。换句话说，西方世界，首先是英国，然后是包括法国在内的其他国家，联手强行打开了中国清朝的大门。清朝自 17 世纪末（1644年）以来一直坐在这个皇位上。正如你所说，这个王朝在很大程度上和之前的中国王朝一样，一直视自己为文明的中心、世界的中心。突然之间，这些外国人，这些来自外部的人物，带着他们巨大的铁甲舰来了。蛮夷。我对于将“夷”翻译为“野蛮人”（barbarians）一直有点谨慎，尽管这是一个很好的简便说法。它当然带有一种略带戏谑的轻蔑意味，但我们有时会在其中加入
our own interpretations on that. So certainly unwelcome foreigners, I would say. And essentially, the tables are turned in the late 19th century, the power of Western industrialization, and also the emergence of Christianity, of Western political thinking. And of course, I mentioned before, I mentioned again, that immensely powerful and highly desired good opium is brought into China and essentially turns the power relationship away from China towards the West. And for the next few decades, you basically get a period in which China is increasingly assaulted territorially and in terms of its own sovereignty by outside powers who either tear out physical chunks, Hong Kong being a good example of that, or else more existentially, force, for instance, the imposition of tariffs onto China that are not controlled by the Chinese
我们自己的解释。所以我认为，这当然是不受欢迎的外国人。从根本上说，在 19世纪末，攻守之势异也，西方工业化的力量，以及基督教和西方政治思想的崛起兴起。当然，正如我之前提到、也将再次提到的那样，那种极其强大且备受追捧的好东西——鸦片被引入中国，从根本上将权力关系从中国转向了西方。在接下来的几十年里，你基本上迎来了一个时期，中国在领土和自身主权方面越来越多地遭到外部势力的攻击，这些外部势力要么通过武力割走大块领土（香港就是一个很好的例子），要么更具实质性地强迫中国，例如强加关税，而这些关税并不受中国
government. So essentially, foreigners are providing a customs authority that means that China doesn't get to control its own import and export tariffs. And if there are any people who have studied the Brexit debates in the contemporary era, you will perhaps hear some echoes of why they've got at least some Chinese very, very, very angry. And to move it on to the 20th century, although all of these tensions came together to see the overthrow of the last emperor, the boy emperor of China, Puyi, some people might remember from Bertolucci's movie from 30 or so years ago, five years old, kicked off the throne of China, and China became Asia's first republic in 1912. It didn't stop the problem, essentially, of China being a weak
政府的控制。因此，本质上，外国人提供了一个海关管理机构，这意味着中国无法控制自己的进出口关税。如果有任何人研究过当代有关英国脱欧的辩论，你或许会听到一些回响，明白为什么这会激怒至少一部分中国人。将时间推进到 20世纪，尽管所有这些紧张局势汇聚在一起，导致了末代皇帝——中国的幼帝溥仪被推翻——有些人可能还记得大约 30 年前贝托鲁奇的电影里那个五岁、被踢下中国皇位的溥仪，中国由此成为了亚洲第一个共和国（1912年）。这并没有从根本上解决中国成为一个弱国的问题，
country that had an unstable government, in which power either lay with foreign powers who essentially have these, you know, rights of conquest, or with a group of Chinese militarists, sometimes nicknamed warlords, essentially men with armies of their own at regional level who were always vying for control. And that meant that by the 1910s, 1920s, you get a lot of Chinese nationalists, young patriots, often students, who demonstrate over and over again demanding that China has to get its act together. China's elites have to get their act together.
其政府并不稳定，权力要么掌握在实际上拥有这些征服权的外国列强手中，要么掌握在一群中国军阀手中——有时被称为军阀，本质上是地区级别拥有自己军队、总是争夺控制权的人们。这意味着到了 1910 年代、1920 年代，你看到了大量中国民族主义者、年轻爱国者（通常是学生），他们一次又一次地游行示威，要求中国必须振作起来。中国的精英们必须振作起来。
One of the phrases that's used at the time is that China was suffering from imperialism from outside and warlordism from inside. And for some of these young nationalists, the answer was two gentlemen, as they put it, Mr. Science and Mr. Democracy, which are going to come together and somehow eventually save China. And then lots of things emerge from that. We can't go into huge detail, but Chinese communism emerges as a small party that becomes a large party in the 1920s. But before that, the man who really takes control of the agenda is the leader of China's nationalist party, sometimes known as the Kuomintang or Kuomintang. You may have seen that abbreviation. It's a party founded by a man named Sun Yat-sen, one of the great nationalist leaders of China,
当时流行的一句话是，中国遭受着来自外部的帝国主义和来自内部的军阀主义的双重折磨。对于其中一些年轻的民族主义者来说，解决的办法是两位先生，正如他们所说的那样，德先生和赛先生，他们将结合起来并最终以某种方式拯救中国。随后，许多事物由此诞生。我们无法深入探讨巨大细节，中国共产主义在 1920 年代作为一个小党派出现，并最终发展成为一个大党。但在那之前，真正掌控议程的人是国民党（或 Kuomintang）的领导人。你可能见过这个缩写。这是一个由孙中山创立的政党，孙中山是中国伟大的民族主义领袖之一，
but he died in 1925 of cancer. And his successor, Chiang Kai-shek, who will be tremendously important to our story of the war, becomes literally a man on horseback leading an expedition that very tentatively reunites China under one government in 1928 based in the capital of the city of Nanjing. But in doing so, he slaughters the communists who had temporarily been his allies. And he turns against them and basically sees them as a sort of snake in the grass who have to be wiped out. And that is the sort of position of China in the period leading up to the war. Just to flip to the Japanese side for a couple of moments, I said there were two ideological forces
但他于 1925 年因癌症逝世。他的继任者蒋介石在我们关于战争的故事中将具有极其重要的意义，他真正成为了一名骑在马背上的领袖，领导了一场北伐，在 1928 年勉强将中国重新统一在一个以南京为首都的政府之下。但在这样做的同时，他大肆屠杀了一度曾是其盟友的共产党人。他调转枪头反对他们，基本上将他们视作必须被铲除的暗中威胁。这就是战争爆发前夕中国的处境。为了花一点时间转向日本方面，我刚才说过有两个意识形态力量
that really shaped this moment. One is that Chinese nationalism that emerges during that time. The other is Japanese imperialism, because it's worth remembering that the only country in the world that had a modern empire like the British, the French, the Americans, or the Americans don't like to admit this, just ask the Filipinos if you doubt it. The Japanese created a modernized empire of their own by basically modernizing very, very fast in the late 19th century, a period known as the Meiji Restoration. They modernized the army, education system, railways, but also started to build their own empire as a way of showing they were sitting at
真正塑造了这一时刻。一个是那个时期崛起的中国民族主义。另一个是日本帝国主义，因为值得记住的是，世界上唯一一个拥有像英、法、美那样现代化帝国的国家——或者说美国人不喜欢承认这一点，如果你怀疑的话去问问菲律宾人就知道了——日本通过在 19世纪末极其迅速地实现现代化，即所谓的明治维新时期，建立了自己的现代化帝国。他们现代化了军队、教育系统、铁路，同时也开始建立自己的帝国，以此来证明他们正跻身于
the top table of international politics. And huge amounts of Asia began to fall to them by the late 19th century. 1895, Taiwan is conquered by the Japanese. 1910, Korea becomes a colony of Japan. Even before that, 1904 to 5, the Russo-Japanese War, despite the title, actually fought on Chinese territory, the northeastern territory of Manchuria. Some parts of that go over to the Japanese. And then the big one in 1931, which is an increasingly confrontational, aggressive Japanese empire that's abandoned democracy by that stage, has a coup essentially launched by Japanese junior officers in this huge territory of Manchuria, about the size of France and Germany combined, and essentially turns it
国际政治的高层牌桌。到 19世纪末，亚洲的大片地区开始落入他们手中。1895 年，台湾被日本征服。1910 年，朝鲜成为日本的殖民地。甚至在此之前，即 1904 至 1905 年的日俄战争，尽管名字叫日俄战争，实际上却是在中国领土——东北的满洲领土上打响的。其中的一些部分落入了日本手中。然后是 1931 年的重大事件，一个日益具有对抗性、侵略性的日本帝国，在这个阶段已经放弃了民主，在满洲这片面积相当于法国和德国总和的大片领土上，由日本低级军官发动了一场政变，并基本上将其
into a puppet state, a client state under Japanese control. And that's where the emperor turns up again, isn't it? If I remember the film right. That's exactly right. So they need it because the technical case, which is a little bit actually like the way in the era we're talking about, Putin's Russia has created supposedly autonomous little kingdoms or stateless republics on the edge of Ukraine and claimed that they're independent states that are being just supported by Russia. Similarly, the Japanese, when they conquered Manchuria, didn't make it a formal colony. They claimed it was a new independent state called Manchukuo. And to find a figurehead for it in 1932, they came across the deposed last emperor of China, Pu Yi, who by now, of course, was a young man, no longer a boy. And he was essentially plucked from Beijing, put on the throne and ruled, very unhappily actually, as the emperor of Manchukuo from 1932 all the way to 1945 and the end of World War II. He eventually died, I should say, in 1966 as a sort of reformed figure in Beijing. Gardner, didn't he? He became a gardener. Yeah, he's a gardener at the end of the film, isn't he?
变成了受日本控制的傀儡国、附庸国。这就是皇帝再次出现的地方，对吧？如果我没记映电影的话。完全正确。所以他们需要它，因为从技术上讲，这有点像在我们谈论的这个时代，普京的俄罗斯在乌克兰边缘制造所谓的自治小王国或无国会共和国，并声称它们是仅受到俄罗斯支持的独立国家。同样地，日本在征服满洲时，并没有将其设为正式的殖民地。他们声称这是一个名为“满洲国”的新独立国家。为了在 1932 年为其找到一个傀儡元首，他们找来了被废黜的中国末代皇帝溥仪。此时的溥仪当然已经是个年轻人，不再是小男孩了。他基本上被从北京抓走，扶上了皇位，并以满洲国皇帝的身份，非常不快乐地进行统治，从 1932 年一直统治到 1945 年二战结束。顺便说一句，他最终于 1966 年在北京作为某种改造后的形象去世了。园丁，对吧？他成了一名园丁。是的，他在电影最后是个园丁，对吧？
That's right. So, Ron, I've got three questions. You're such a brilliant speaker that I've probably got about 50 questions during the course of your... Peroration. Peroration. That may be code for I'm going on too long. No, no, no. It's not at all. It's not at all.
没错。所以，拉纳，我有三个问题。你是一位如此出色的演讲者，以至于在你的……结束语。结束语期间，我大概想出了大约 50 个问题。这可能是暗指我说得太久了。不，不，不。完全不是。完全不是。
Because I was actually thinking this is so good that I could actually just sneak out of the room and make a tea or something. But okay. So here are my three questions. Question one. When 1931 happens, so that's the so-called the Manchurian incident or the Mukden incident, the Japanese, it's a sort of false flag operation, isn't it? They have a bomb that goes off by the railway that they planted themselves and they say, oh, the Chinese are attacking us. Oh, this is, we must immediately take over Manchuria. That's exactly right.
因为我刚才其实在想，这讲得太棒了，我甚至可以悄悄溜出房间去泡杯茶什么的。好吧。所以这是我的三个问题。问题一。当 1931 年的事变发生时，也就是所谓的满洲事变或九一八事变，日本人——这实际上是一个假旗行动（嫁祸行动），对吧？他们在铁轨旁引爆了一枚他们自己安放的炸弹，然后说：“哦，中国人正在袭击我们。哦，这太糟了，我们必须立即接管满洲。”完全正确。
First of all, why are there Japanese troops already in parts of China? Because there are Japanese sort of bases and things in China, aren't there? So why is that? So a phrase that you'll quite often hear, and it's actually a Marxist phrase, but it's been used more broadly speaking, because I'm sure you always love a bit of Marxism on the rest of history. Love it. Dominic loves it. Yeah. Get it in there. Dominic's particularly fond of it, I'm sure. The phrase semi-colonial, which is a rather unsatisfactory phrase in some ways that's used to describe the state of China during that time. China was never a formal colony other than some small parts like Hong Kong and also lesser known places like Weihaiwei. But the vast majority of China's territory technically was sovereign.
首先，为什么日本军队当时已经在中国的一些地方了？因为中国有一些日本的基地和类似的东西，对吧？那这是为什么呢？所以你会经常听到一个短语，它实际上是一个马克思主义短语，但它已被更广泛地使用——因为我确信你们在《历史的余烬》中总是喜欢一点马克思主义。太喜欢了。多米尼克很喜欢。加进来吧。多米尼克对此格外情有独钟，我确信。半殖民地这个词，在某种程度上是一个相当令人不满意的词，用来描述当时中国的状态。除了香港等少数几个小地方以及威海卫等鲜为人知的地方之外，中国从来不是一个正式的殖民地。但中国绝大多数的领土在技术上是主权独立的。
They were a member of the League of Nations, for instance, the interwar predecessor of the United Nations. Can I just ask about Shanghai? Yes. And what the state is there? Because that is, is that unusual? Because there, there does seem to be kind of distinctive European territory carved out. Great, great question. And I'm going to make a shameless plug here by saying that, you know, one of these days,
例如，他们是国际联盟的成员，即联合国在两战之间的前身。我能问一下关于上海的事吗？可以。那里的状态是怎样的？因为那是——那是不寻常的吗？因为那里似乎开辟出了一种独特的欧洲领土。问得好，问得妙。我在这里要厚着脸皮插一句，（开玩笑地说）总有一天，
the discussion of the Shanghai International Settlement and its century of existence is one of the other great stories that I'm sure will make a wonderful podcast. Just putting that in there. We would love to do that. That is a great idea. But put very briefly, in 1843, just after that opium war that I'm sure will make a wonderful podcast. Just putting that in there. We would love to do that. That is a great idea. But put very briefly, in 1843, just after that opium war that I've mentioned, the Treaty of Nanjing is signed in 1842. The most famous aspect of that these days is the handover of Hong Kong, because that has now, of course, become quite a current issue as Hong Kong
关于上海公共租界及其一个世纪存在的讨论，将是另一大精彩故事，我相信它会做成一档绝佳的播客节目。先把它放在这里。我们很乐意做那一期。那是个好主意。但简而言之，在 1843 年，就在那场我确信会做成一档绝佳播客节目的鸦片战争之后——先把它放在这里。我们很乐意做那一期。那是个好主意。但简而言之，在 1843 年，就在我提到的那场鸦片战争之后，1842 年签署了《南京条约》。如今最著名的一个方面是香港的移交，因为随着香港在几年前根据《国家安全法》被接管，这现在当然成了一个颇具时效性的议题。但其中的另一条条款基本上开放了五个中国港口，本质上作为某种不受中国主权管辖、或不完全受中国主权管辖的自治自由港。而上海成为了其中最成功的一个。所以本质上，在很短时间内，从 1840 年代开始，上海市的一部分——实际上那变成了一种由法国统治的殖民地，被称为法租界。这比较直截了当，就是城市内部的一个小小殖民地。第二部分比较大，也更复杂。
has been locked down under the national security law a couple of years ago. But one of the other clauses basically opened up five Chinese ports, essentially as sort of autonomous free ports that were not under Chinese sovereignty, or not fully under Chinese sovereignty. And Shanghai became the most successful of them. So essentially, within a short period of time, in the 1840s onwards, one section of Shanghai city became, actually that became a sort of colony, which was governed by the French. It's called the French concessions. That's more straightforward, a kind of little colony inside the city. The second part, which was larger, was more complicated.
被称为公共租界。这是一个略具误导性的名称，因为它本质上是上海土地上的一种英国殖民地，但并非由殖民地总督统治（所以不像印度，甚至不像香港），而是由上海工部局（Municipal Committee）治理。换句话说，基本上是由纳税人组成的集团。因此有英国人、日本人、美国人——而且，我总是想把美国人也卷入亚洲帝国的血色故事中，因为他们总是侥幸逃脱，自称是反帝国主义者。我想确保他们就在这个故事的正中心。他们基本上通过征税来管理这座城市，但在进入 20世纪之前，这座城市中国居民的权利却少之又少。我能与之相比的最接近的东西也许是一个定居者社群，可能有点像罗得西亚。换句话说，
It was called the International Settlement. That's a slightly misleading name because it's essentially a form of British colony on the soil of Shanghai, but governed not by a colonial governor, so not like India or even like Hong Kong, instead governed by the Shanghai Municipal Committee. In other words, a group of rate payers, essentially. So British, Japanese, Americans, and again, I always want to dip the blood of the Americans into the story of empire in Asia, because they always get away with claiming that they're anti-imperialists. And I want to make sure that they're right in the middle of the story. They basically raise taxes to run the city, but there are very few rights given to Chinese residents of that part of the city until into the 20th century. The nearest thing I can compare it to perhaps is a settler community, perhaps a bit like Rhodesia. In other
这当然是一种殖民状况，但城市本身是由一个主要由英国人（但在此期间并不完全由英国人）组成的委员会来管理的，它并不直接受伦敦殖民地办公室的控制，就像那些完全的殖民地那样。之所以这很重要，原因之一在于，英国外交部在 20世纪初越来越多的文件里表现出越来越 exasperated（恼怒）的语气，基本上说他们想告诉上海的英国社群该怎么做——正如历史学家罗伯特·比克斯（Robert Bickers）所写的那样，被称作“上海人”（Shanghailanders）的社群——但他们拒绝照办，
words, it is of course a colonial situation, but the city itself is run by a committee largely of britains but not exclusively during that period and it's not directly under the control of the colonial office in the way that full colonies were one of the reasons that that matters is that the british foreign office you find more and more exasperated notes in the early 20th century basically saying that they want to tell the shanghai british community what to do the shanghai landers as the historian robert bickers has written about about them um community what to do. The Shanghailanders, as the historian Robert Bickers has written about them, refusing basically to do what they're told
只是自顾自地做他们感兴趣的事。但本质上，这是一个半自治的、主要由英国人管理的城市。关于这一点，我还想补充一点，这常常被人们遗忘。我们有些人想到英国殖民地的大城市时，会想到孟买、加尔各答、比勒陀利亚、开普敦。但人们常常忘记，上海在很大程度上也是一座英国殖民地城市。
and just getting on with whatever they're actually interested in. But essentially, it's a semi-autonomous, largely British-run city. I want to further note on that, actually, it's often forgotten. Some of us think of the great cities of British colonialism, Bombay, Calcutta, Pretoria, Cape Town. But people forget that Shanghai is very much a British colonial city.
如果你走到江边，走到今天依然著名的外滩，看看那些带有曼彻斯特风格的大型装饰艺术建筑，你就会明白，英国对这座城市的影响直至今日依然是多么深远。还有汇丰银行，对吧？当然是汇丰银行。香港上海汇丰银行。
And if you go to the waterfront, the famous Bund, even today, look at those huge Art Deco buildings that have a touch of Manchester about them as well. You will see quite how longstanding the British influence on the city remains even now. And HSBC, isn't it? HSBC, of course. The Hong Kong and Shanghai Bank.
香港上海汇丰银行。不过事实上，我听说过这样一个故事：在 2000 年代资本主义卷土重来之后，现今的上海市政府曾以某种极其敲诈勒索的价格向汇丰银行提议，把那栋大楼买回去。但汇丰银行认为，其实他们无法真正从那栋大楼里经营一家现代银行。所以那栋建筑现在好像成了中国经营的浦东发展银行。而今天的汇丰银行实际上在对岸充满未来感的新浦东新区。
The Hong Kong and Shanghai Bank. Although actually, I believe the story is that after, you know, when things got back to capitalism back in the 2000s, the city council of Shanghai in the present day offered HSBC the building back for some incredibly extortionate price. But HSBC, I think, realised that in fact, they couldn't really run a modern bank out of that building. So that building is, I think, now the Pudong Development Bank run by the Chinese. And today's HSBC is actually across the water in the futuristic New Pudong District.
但如果你走进老香港上海汇丰银行大楼——在正常时期，没有大流行病等等的情况下，游客是允许进去的——然后抬头看，你会看到这幅奇妙的壁画，上面画着香港上海汇丰银行运营过的八大城市，显然有香港和上海，还有曼谷以及当时帝国的其他城市。画得非常精美，是一幅非常非常有趣的壁画。如果你去不了上海（目前可能确实去不了），你其实可以在互联网上找到那个图像。非常值得一看。所以，拉纳，把话题拉回日本人身上。日本人是那些基本上拥有小小立足点的列强之一，对吧？他们在满洲有铁路，但在全中国也有各种兵营之类的地方。所以我的问题是，为什么他们还不满足？换句话说，为什么会有这种
But if you go into the old Hong Kong Shanghai Bank building, which in normal times, non-pandemic and so forth, tourists are allowed to do. And then look up, you will see this fantastic mural with pictures of the eight great cities that the Hong Kong Shanghai Bank operated in, obviously Hong Kong and Shanghai, but also Bangkok and other cities of empire of that time. Beautifully painted and a really, really interesting mural. And if you can't get to Shanghai, which you probably can't at the moment, you can find that image on the internet, actually. It's well worth looking at. So Ron, to take you back to the Japanese, the Japanese are one of the powers, aren't they, that have basically got a little toehold. And they have this railway in Manchuria, but they also have barracks all over China and things. So my question is, why aren't they happy with that? So in other words, why is there this
内在的动力、这种不安分，促使日本人在 20世纪 30 年代甚至想要在军事上卷入中国？是什么在推动这一切？主要的推动力——虽然有很多驱动因素，但要说到最主要的驱动力，那就是情绪。日本是唯一一个在 1850 年代几乎面临被西方列强殖民的危险、而在半个世纪后成为一个名副其实的殖民强国的非欧洲国家，它经历了一次惊人的迅速崛起。他们看着 20世纪 20 和 30 年代西方帝国似乎已经尘埃落定的局面——我的意思是，现存的殖民地并没有被归还，但当时也有一种感觉，即英国和法国的殖民地不应再扩张，其中一些应该变成国际联盟委任统治地，换汤不换药的殖民地，
internal dynamism, this restlessness, that means the Japanese even want to get involved in China militarily in the 1930s? What is driving all that? The primary driver, and there are a lot of them, but to go to the primary driver is emotional. Japan was the only non-European nation to have made this astonishingly rapid rise from being a country that was nearly in danger of being colonized itself by western powers in the 1850s to being a colonial power in its own right half a century later and they looked at the way that by the 1920s and 30s as you know western empires tended to be settled i mean the colonies that existed weren't being given back but there was also a feeling that british uh colonies and french colonies shouldn't expand at that time and some of them should be turned into League of Nations mandates, colonies by another name,
你可能会这么说，但不管怎样。日本人非常明确且经常地指出：“听着，这不公平。我们加入帝国游戏的时间比较晚。凭什么英国人和法国人在非洲和亚洲拥有这么大片领土却能保留它们，而当我们想做类似的事情时，人们却说不再被允许了？”因此，这种情绪我认为是其中很大的一部分。第二部分我认为与此相关，但也许略有不同，那就是受到大萧条的推动。本质上，在 20世纪 20 年代末，当世界在大萧条和华尔街股灾之后转向经济自给自足时，日本发现自己被越来越多地排挤在国际市场之外。我有时喜欢说——这是我的另一个小短语，如果你愿意，大可以把它批得体无完肤：第二次世界大战部分是由美国女性的丝袜挑起的，
you might say, but nonetheless. And the Japanese quite explicitly said quite often, well, look, this isn't fair. We came along late to the game of empire. Why on earth should the British and French get to keep this huge swathe of territory they have around the world in Africa and Asia? But when we want to do something similar, people say it's no longer permitted. So that emotion, I think, is a large part of it. The second part that I think links to that, but it's perhaps slightly separate, is pushed by the Great Depression. Essentially, in the late 1920s, when the world turns to economic autarky in the aftermath of the Depression and the Wall Street crash, Japan found itself being increasingly shut out of international markets. I sometimes like to say, here's another one of my little phrases, you're welcome to pick
因为在 20世纪初，日本的工业实力很大一部分在于轻工业纺织品。换句话说，年轻女性——通常是年轻女性——在日本工厂里恶劣的环境下工作，因为所有的纤维而患上肺病，生产棉织品和丝绸产品，包括丝袜。而在 20世纪 20 年代，当《斯穆特-霍利关税法》以及其他关税阻止日本商品甚至是绝大多数外国商品进入美国时，这类商品市场的崩溃意味着中国的——抱歉，日本的农村经济非常、非常迅速地被摧毁了。所有的这些农村年轻男女突然发现自己基本上失去了出口市场。当然，这助长了一种愤怒的政治情绪，政客们被质问：“你们打算对此做些什么？”而这种质问的答案在某些情况下往往是：“我们在自己的地区利益范围内进行扩张。”具体而言，这意味着中国大陆。
apart if you like. World War II was started in part by American women's silk stockings, because a large part of Japan's industrial strength in the early 20th century was in light industrial textiles. In other words, young women, quite often it was young women, working in Japanese factories in horrible conditions, getting lung diseases from all the fibers, making cotton and silk products, including stockings. And in the 1920s, when the Smoot-Hawley and other terrorists prevented exports of Japanese and indeed most foreign goods
这就是为什么你会看到——拥有这些驻军的原因。本质上，日本利用其军事优势来宣称它拥有特殊的权利——再次说明，你在这里可能又会听到普京的俄罗斯与乌克兰的共鸣——在靠近它的地理区域内拥有特殊权利，还有什么地方能比中国更近呢？并本质上利用中国内部政治的软弱，强迫中国统治者签署协议，允许日本军队驻扎在中国领土上，表面上是为了保护日本的利益。再次强调，不断回到与普京的比较中：如果日本平民发现自己受到侮辱、伤害或伤害，那么日本军队就被允许基本上
coming into the United States, the collapse in market for these sorts of goods meant that China, sorry, Japan's rural economy was destroyed, you know, very, very quickly. And all of these rural young women and men suddenly found themselves essentially without an export market. And that fueled, of course, an angry politics, which said, well, what are you going to do about it to the politicians? And the answer tended in some cases to say, well, we expand in our areas of regional interest. In particular, that means the mainland of China.
前来营救他们。正如你所想象的，发生过不止一次这样的事件：日本平民发现自己受到了恶劣对待，可能其中包含某些挑衅成分，这使得日本的军事存在得以进一步扩大。所以这本质上意味着，日本在中国建立的非正式帝国在 20世纪 20 和 30 年代变得非常庞大，而且坦率地说，到了那个阶段已经不算是什么非正式的了。但是拉纳，我能——为了把镜头彻底拉远，中国和日本之间的关系——我的意思是，这是一个非常古老的关系，显然，他们在地理上非常接近。历史上，日本深受中国的影响。对于作为自身文化发源地以及这个极其古老文明的中国，日本人是否仍然存在某种自卑情结？还是说他们已经完全压抑了这种情结？他们现在是否带着蔑视来看待中国人？在 19世纪末到 20世纪初之间，中日之间经历了一场真实的情绪再平衡。
So that's the reason why you get the reason that you get these troops being stationed. Essentially, Japan used its military superiority to make the case that it had special rights. Again, you may be hearing echoes of Putin in Russia and Ukraine here again, special rights in geographical areas that were close to it and where could be closer than China, and essentially use the weakness of China's internal politics to force Chinese rulers to sign agreements that Japanese troops could be stationed on Chinese territory, ostensibly to protect Japanese interests. And again, keep coming back to the Putin comparison. If Japanese civilians found themselves being insulted or injured or hurt, then Japanese troops were allowed to basically
它有两个几乎彼此对立的部分。用一个中国词来说，可以说是阴阳相成。一方面，这是不可否认的。但到了 20世纪初，日本是区域和全球政治中更有力量的参与者。因为它的工业化更成功。它的工业化更成功。它更富有，并且能够行使自己的意志。
come and save them. And as you can imagine, there was more than one incident in which Japanese civilians found themselves being treated badly, possibly with an element of provocation, which allowed that Japanese military presence to expand even further. So that essentially meant the informal empire that Japan had in China became very extensive by the 1920s and 30s, and frankly, wasn't all that informal by that stage. But Brandon, can I just, just to pull the camera right back, the relationship between China and Japan, I mean, it's very, it's a very long one, obviously, they're very geographically close. Historically, Japan had been hugely influenced by China. Is there any sense still of an inferiority complex that the Japanese have towards China as the kind of birthplace of its own culture and this immensely ancient civilization? Or have they completely suppressed that? Do they now regard the Chinese with contempt? There's a real emotional rebalancing that goes on between China and Japan between the late 19th and early 20th century.
因此，当时中国的许多精英中产生了一种强烈的感受：天哪，我们必须向日本学习，因为他们显然已经找到了如何击退外国人并让自己变得强大的方法。许多中国精英的这种感受——比如梁启超，晚清中国伟大的知识分子之一，最终甚至去了日本的人，所以他感到某种程度的契合。他们花了大量时间来研究为什么日本成功了
And it has two parts which sit almost in opposition to each other. Yin and yang, you might say, to use a Chinese phrase. On the one hand, it was undeniable. But by the early 20th century, Japan was the more powerful actor in regional and in global politics. Because it's industrialized more successfully. It industrialized more successfully. It's richer and it was able to exercise its will.
而我们却失败了。在日本方面，我认为有一种复杂的情感，因为你所提到的漫长的中国文化传统（儒家传统，将古典汉语作为语言工具的传统）是如此悠久，以至于不可能一朝一夕被彻底推翻。因此，既有一种几乎是老大哥倒退了而小弟弟必须被带入现代性的怨恨感，又夹杂着各种复杂的情感。值得一提的是，有件事有时在仇恨的故事中被淡化了——在那个时期以及随后，许多中国人和日本人之间的仇恨变得非常真实——这就是，尽管有帝国统治（这与英法帝国也有相似之处），
And therefore, there was a strong sense amongst many of China's elites at that time. My gosh, we have to learn from Japan because they've obviously worked out how to push back the foreigners and actually become strong themselves. And that sense of many Chinese elites, people like Liang Qichao, one of the great intellectuals of late 19th century China and a figure who eventually actually went to Japan in the end. So he felt something of an affinity. They spent a lot of time actually working out why on earth has Japan succeeded
尽管日本在中国的征服激起了愤怒，但也存在着一定程度的文化互动，而且在文化阵营中，与军事阵营相比，实际上有一种更加平等主义的感觉。因此，许多中国年轻人凭借日本奖学金前往东京和中国留学。虽然他们对这些奖学金可能附带的那种居高临下的施舍感多少有些怨恨，但有机会来到一个像东京这样的大都市中心——韩国人会来，东南亚人会来，中国人和日本人也都会来——被视为一种文化大熔炉，它实际上承认了中国、日本
and we have failed. On the Japanese side, I think there was a sort of ambiguity of feeling because the long Chinese cultural tradition that you've mentioned, the Confucian tradition, tradition of using classical Chinese as a linguistic tool, was so longstanding that it couldn't simply be overthrown at one blow. And therefore, the mixture of feelings of both kind of almost resentment that the elder brother had fallen backwards and that the younger brother had to be sort of brought into modernity was found there. It's worth saying one of the things, I think this sometimes gets a bit lost in the story of the hatred, which became very real between many Chinese and many Japanese during that time and subsequently, which is that despite empire, and there are parallels here actually with the British and the French empires too,
和其他东亚人之间存在着大量共享文化的事实。所以双方的情感是相当矛盾的。但毫无疑问，总体而言，随着日本走向这种大亚洲主义（Pan-Asianism）的理念，即把自己视为必须为其他亚洲国家指明道路的一流亚洲强国，他们绝对让自己陷入了一种俯视其他亚洲国家的姿态。对此毫无疑问。拉纳，在我们继续推进到 1937 年之前，还有一个问题。多米尼克，你的两个问题已经问过了吗？
despite the anger that came from Japanese conquest in China, there was also a certain amount of cultural interaction and actually a feeling of more egalitarianism on the cultural front as opposed to necessarily the military front. So a lot of young Chinese came on Japanese scholarships to study in Tokyo and in China. And while they somewhat resented, you know, the kind of rather condescending charity that might be associated with these scholarships, the opportunity to actually come to a metropolitan center, which Tokyo was, you know, where Koreans would come, where Southeast Asians would come, where Chinese would come, as well as Japanese, was regarded as a sort of cultural melting pot that actually acknowledged the fact that there was a lot of shared culture between China, Japan,
尽管日本对中国的侵略引发了愤怒，但在文化层面上也存在一定程度的文化交流，而且实际上与军事前线相比，文化领域有一种更具平等主义的感觉。因此，许多中国年轻人通过日本奖学金来到东京和中国学习。虽然他们对这些奖学金可能伴随的那种相当居高临下的施舍心存不满，但能够来到像东京这样的大都市中心——韩国人、东南亚人、中国人和日本人都会来到这里——的机会，被视为一种文化大熔炉，它实际上承认了中国、日本以及其他东亚地区之间存在大量共享文化的事实。
and other East Asians as well. So it's quite an ambivalent set of feelings on both sides. But there's no doubt that overall, the Japanese, as they move towards this idea of pan-Asianism, of themselves as a sort of first-class Asian power who has to show the other Asian powers the way, that they definitely got themselves into a position where they were looking to lord it over the other Asian nations. There's little doubt about that. Rana, one more question before we move on towards 1937. Dominic, have you had your two questions already?
以及其他东亚国家也是如此。因此，双方都有一组相当矛盾的情感。但毫无疑问，总体而言，当日本人走向泛亚洲主义的概念，把自己视为必须给其他亚洲强国指明道路的一流亚洲强国时，他们确实让自己处于一种想要对其他亚洲国家颐指气使的地位。这一点几乎毫无疑问。拉娜，在我们转向1937年之前，还有一个问题。多米尼克，你已经问过两个问题了吗？
No, this is my final question, Tom. This is my third question. So I've been very good at keeping my questions kind of hanging. So Rana uh why isn't 1931 the beginning of the second world war because that's the moment when you have this false flag operation and the japanese as you said they can't they basically conquer an area the size of france and germany put together in manchuria and they set up their puppet state and that's a from the sort of perspective of the league of nations and sort of western opinion that's seen as a sort of flagrant act of aggression and annexation. So why isn't that the beginning? Why isn't that the turning point? Well, first of all, Dominic, if you go to China and say what I've just said, which is that it starts, I think, in 1937 properly, you can get into big trouble these days.
不，这是我的最后一个问题，汤姆。这是我的第三个问题。我一直很擅长让我的问题保持悬念。那么拉纳，呃，为什么1931年不是第二次世界大战的开始呢？因为那是你所说的那个伪旗行动发生的时刻，日本人——正如你所说——他们征服了一个相当于法国和德国加起来那么大的满洲里地区，他们建立了自己的傀儡政权。从国联和西方舆论的角度来看，这被视为一种公然的侵略和兼并行为。那么，为什么这不是开始呢？为什么这不是转折点呢？好吧，首先，多米尼克，如果你去中国说我刚才说的话——也就是我认为它真正开始于1937年——你现在可能会惹上大麻烦。
So a little bit of political subversion right here on the podcast, you know, send it over to Beijing now and let's get the handcuffs out. Because about four years ago, it was actually legally decreed in China that the official start of World War II is 1931 because of the Manchurian incident. And that's now an officially maintained position. So for instance, books in China have had textbooks have had to be changed to reflect that. Prior to that, there was a very lively debate in the Chinese academic world, and that still actually does, you know, exist, I think, although not so officially now, about whether it was 1931 or 1937. Just to add to the mix, actually, for a very long time, certainly during the Cold War years, the Japanese, particularly the Japanese left,
所以，这简直是在播客里进行一点政治颠覆，你知道，现在把它发给北京，把手铐拿出来吧。因为大约四年前，中国实际上通过法律正式规定，由于九一八事变，第二次世界大战的官方起始时间是1931年。这现在是一个官方坚持的立场。因此，例如，中国的教科书不得不进行修改以反映这一点。在此之前，中国学术界曾有过非常激烈的辩论，事实上这种辩论至今仍然存在，我认为，尽管现在不像以前那样具有官方色彩了，即究竟是1931年还是1937年。为了让情况更复杂一点，事实上，在很长一段时间里，当然是在冷战时期，日本人，特别是日本左翼，
have referred to this whole period, I always think slightly mysteriously, as Jugo Nen no Senso, the 15-year war. I'm not quite sure how 1931 to 45 counts as 15 unless you sort of actually count the fullness of each particular year. But you know, never mind that. The point is that the Japanese have also seen this as a long period in which there is a continuity. However, here are the reasons briefly that I think that 1937 is the starting point. First of all, during the war itself, and for many, many decades afterwards, the Chinese who were fighting it thought it had begun in 1937. So at the end of 1945, when the war was over, all Chinese newspapers, commentators,
一直把这段时期——我总觉得有点神秘地——称为“十五年战争”。我不太确定1931年到45年怎么能算作15年，除非你把每个特定年份的完整性都计算在内。但你知道，没关系。重点是，日本人也将此视为一段具有连续性的漫长时期。然而，简而言之，我认为1937年是起点的原因如下。首先，在战争期间以及之后的很多很多年里，参与战斗的中国人都认为战争始于1937年。因此，在1945年底战争结束后，所有中国报纸、评论员、
you know, journalists, writers, historians, talked about the great eight-year war of resistance against Japan that they had fought, Ban Yan Kang Zhang in Chinese. Nobody at that point talked about, or very few people, I should think, talked about it being a 14-year war. So, in that sense, I would give the contemporary survivors of the war a certain amount of leeway. But leaving that aside, there are analytical reasons, I think, as well. And I'll just go for one. If you look at what happens after 1931 and this conquest and annexation of Manchuria into a client state of Japan, it's not a straight downhill path from there all the way to the outbreak of war in 1937.
你知道的，记者、作家、历史学家，都在谈论他们所进行伟大的八年抗日战争，中文里叫作“八年抗战”。在那时，没有人谈论——或者极少数人谈论——这是一场十四年的战争。因此，从这个意义上说，我对当时战争的幸存者持一定的宽容态度。但撇开这一点不谈，我认为也有分析上的原因。我只说一个。如果你看看1931年之后发生的事情，以及满洲被征服并吞并为日本的附属国，从那时起到1937年战争爆发，并不是一条一路直下的平坦道路。
In 1933, Chiang Kai-shek's nationalist government and the Japanese government at the time undertake an uneasy truce. It's called the Truce of Tangu. And it's basically the beginning of a two-year period when both sides, I think the Chinese more sincerely than the Japanese, to be honest, are trying to reach a new status quo. Again, I'm going to keep reaching for these Putin-type analogies here, but they do seem in so many ways so powerful. So do you think the Ukraine war began in 2014 with Crimea or this February 2022? You don't necessarily have to answer the question, but you see the distinction I'm making there. Lots of people actually now talking about the reinvasion of Ukraine. And you could talk about the restarting of the war in China. But overall,
1933年，蒋介石的国民政府与当时的日本政府达成了一项勉强的休战协议。这被称为《塘沽协定》。基本上，这是双方——老实说，我认为中国比日本更真诚——试图达成一种新现状的两年期的开始。再说一遍，我将继续在这里使用普京式的类比，但它们在很多方面确实显得如此有力。那么，你认为乌克兰战争是从2014年的克里米亚开始的，还是从2022年2月开始的？你不一定非要回答这个问题，但你看得出我所做的区别。事实上，现在有很多人在谈论对乌克兰的重新入侵。你可以谈论中国战争的重新开始。但总体而言，
there was a status quo, a very uneasy status quo achieved certainly by 1933 in Manchuria, and the flare up didn't happen again until 1937. So I might leave you with the way in which Chinese historians today try and square the circle of this distinction. Nowadays, the official position, if you kind of want to say that you think it's really 1937, but you don't want to say it, well, you're not able to say it publicly because it's no longer permitted in textbooks and so forth, is to say that 1931 is the beginning of the overall war of resistance in the Chinese phrase. And then 1937 is the beginning of the full scale war of resistance. And that is a way, I think, of trying to get both of those viewpoints in. But that's why I personally would still stick to 1937 and argue for that as
到1933年，满洲确实实现了一种现状，一种非常勉强的现状，而冲突直到1937年才再次爆发。所以我可以留给你看看今天的中国历史学家是如何试图圆这个区别的圆的。如今，官方立场——如果你想说你认为实际上是1937年，但又不想说，或者说你不能公开说，因为它不再被教科书等允许——是说1931年用中国话说全面抗战的总体开端。然后1937年是全面抗战的开始。我认为，这是一种试图将这两种观点结合起来的方法。但这就是为什么我个人仍然坚持1937年，并将其视为
the beginning of, well, as we've said, the Second World War in Asia, but also actually globally. Okay. Well, I think we should take a break here. And then when we come back, let's look at the start of the outbreak of the full-scale war of resistance, and we'll move to 1937. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And And we'll move to 1937. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news,
正如我们所说，亚洲的第二次世界大战的开始，而且实际上也是全球范围内大战的开始。好的。好吧，我想我们应该在这里休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们来看看全面抗战爆发的开端，我们将进入1937年。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。而——我们将进入1937年。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《余下皆娱乐》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻的固定栏目，
reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History.
评论，以及少许演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前获得现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。
We are looking at what Rana Mehta is, our guest, is casting as the outbreak of the Second World War. And Rana, we have got to 1937. But before the war actually begins, you've been talking about Chiang Kai-shek, the Chinese leader, leader of the nationalists. But there are two other figures who over the course of the war will play very, very significant roles. One of them, very, very famous name, we've already devoted an entire episode to him, Mao Zedong, communist. But the other one, Wang Jingwei, who you describe as a man of extraordinary good looks in your book. What is there to say about Wang Jingwei, other than his extraordinary good looks, that means that he's such a kind of key figure in this story? Albeit one that, you know, compared to Mao and
我们正在探讨我们的嘉宾拉纳·米特将什么事件视为第二次世界大战的爆发。拉纳，我们已经到了1937年。但在战争真正爆发之前，你一直在谈论中国领导人、国民党领袖蒋介石。但在战争过程中，还有另外两个将在其中扮演非常非常重要角色的重要人物。其中一个是非常非常著名的名字，我们已经为他专门做了一整集节目，那就是共产党人毛泽东。但另一个人是汪精卫，你在书中将他描述为一个拥有非凡美貌的男子。除了他非凡的美貌之外，关于汪精卫还有什么要说的，能让他成为这个故事中如此关键的人物？尽管与毛泽东和
Chiang Kai-shek, much less well known. Well, I should say that Wang Jingwei's good looks are not incidental to this man's history, and I'll explain why in a moment. Wang Jingwei was one of the most prominent revolutionaries against the last Chinese dynasty, the Qing dynasty that was overthrown in 1911, 1912. He was an extremely fierce opponent of the Manchu Qing dynasty that ruled China at that time. You can think, you know, in the same way that one thinks of the sort of late 19th century Russian revolutionaries who overthrew the Tsars, you know, they assassinated Alexander III. They weren't immediately successful. There's a lot of persecution, but eventually the Russian revolution overthrew the Bolsheviks as well.
蒋介石相比，他远没有那么知名。好吧，我应该说汪精卫的美貌与这个男人的历史并不是偶然的，我等一下会解释原因。汪精卫是对抗中国最后一个王朝——在1911年、1912年被推翻的清朝——的最著名的革命者之一。他是当时统治中国的满清皇朝的极其激烈的反对者。你可以这样想，就像人们看待19世纪末推翻沙皇的俄国革命者一样，你知道，他们暗杀亚历山大二世。他们并没有立即取得成功。有很多迫害，但最终俄国革命也推翻了布尔什维克。
So Wang Jingwei was very much in that mode of an anti-monarchist, an anti-royalist who was seeking to overthrow the last Chinese dynasty. And his raven-haired beauty was something that was very, very widely noted amongst those people who hung out in revolutionary circles and beyond. It was said that when he was caught, because he took a leaf out of the Russian book and
所以汪精卫非常符合那种反君主制、反保皇派的模式，他试图推翻最后一个中国王朝。他在那些混迹于革命圈子及其他地方的人当中，其一头乌黑亮丽的头发非常非常广为人知。据说当他被抓获时——因为他效仿俄国人的做法，
chucked a bomb at a prince of the Qing royal house, he didn't miss, but it didn't kill him. But he was, of course, nabbed and sentenced to death. And it is said, certainly, that one of the reasons that his sentence was commuted from death to long term imprisonment was that one of the court ladies, the Manchu court, caught sight of him and said, you know, this young man is so good looking, we can't possibly cut his head off. So if that is true, then his chiseled good looks, feel free to put his name into a search engine if you want to see what they look like. Plenty of pictures of him certainly made a difference. But his political significance, for good or ill, doesn't really, in the end, lie on the shoulders of his looks. The best way to think about Wang Jingwei, I think, is as a figure who in some ways is parallel to figures who may be better known to listeners who know the European World War II story, such as
向清朝皇室的一个亲王扔了一颗炸弹，他没有失手，但没能炸死对方。当然，他被捕并被判处死刑。据说，他的死刑被减为长期监禁的原因之一，是清廷的一位宫廷女性看到了他，然后说，你知道，这个年轻人长得太好看了，我们绝对不能砍掉他的头。如果这是真的，那么他雕塑般的美貌——如果你想看看他长什么样，大可以把他的名字输进搜索引擎——大量的照片确实发挥了作用。但无论好坏，他的政治意义最终并不在于他的外表。我认为，理解汪精卫最好的方式，是将他视为在某些方面与那些对欧洲二战故事比较熟悉的听众可能更了解的人物相平行的人物，比如
Laval or Pétain in France or Quisling in Norway. In other words, collaborators with the invaders. And Wang Jingwei is probably the most famous, certainly the most well-known and notorious of those who collaborated with the Japanese during their occupation of China. In the 1920s and 30s, Wang Jingwei became one of the most prominent figures in the nationalist revolution of the time. He was second really in prominence only to Chiang Kai-shek, who became the leader of China once he'd set up his regime at Nanjing in 1928. And Wang Jingwei had a very difficult relationship with him. The two of them never trusted each other an inch. But through much of the 1930s, Wang Jingwei became a very prominent figure in the cabinets of China at that time. He was essentially prime minister at
法国的赖伐尔或贝当，或者挪威的吉斯林。换句话说，就是与侵略者合作的合作者。汪精卫可能是日本占领中国期间与日本人合作的人中最著名、最广为人知、也是最声名狼藉的一个。在20世纪20年代和30年代，汪精卫成为当时国民革命中最杰出的人物之一。在1928年在南京建立政权之后，他的声望实际上仅次于成为中国领导人的蒋介石。汪精卫与他的关系非常艰难。两人从未信任过对方哪怕一英寸。但在20世纪30年代的大部分时间里，汪精卫成为了当时中国内阁中非常显赫的人物。他曾一度基本上是总理，
one point. And he became known as a figure who probably was more sympathetic to the idea of a deal with Japan during the 1930s after the Manchurian incident than some of the other more sort of hardline nationalists in the government. But at that point, there was no doubt that he was regarded as a figure of the highest significance in the Chinese government alongside Chiang Kai-shek and other nationalist figures. So a very prominent national level figure who everyone would have known, rather like a figure like Pierre Laval in France at exactly the same time, the Third Republic. So we'll come back to his story a little bit later. But Rana, you talked about Chiang Kai-shek. And I guess it's easy to have the impression that Chiang Kai-shek is leading a united, coherent China. But am I right in thinking that in that period,
并且他以这样一种形象而闻名：在九一八事变之后，在20世纪30年代，与政府中其他一些更强硬的民族主义者相比，他可能对与日本达成交易的想法更具同情心。但在那个时候，毫无疑问，他被视为中国政府中地位最高的人物，与蒋介石和其他国民党要人并列。因此，这是一个每个人都会知道的非常显赫的国家级人物，就像完全同一时期法兰西第三共和国的皮埃尔·赖伐尔一样。所以我们稍后再回到他的故事。但是拉纳，你谈到了蒋介石。我想人们很容易留下这样的印象：蒋介石领导着一个统一、连贯的中国。但是，如果我以为在那个时期，
coming up to 1937, the warlordism, as it were, is not quite as bad as it was. But China is still pretty divided, isn't it? So you have Chiang Kai-shek and the nationalists. You also have Mao and the communists who've done their long march. So they've kind of gone into the countryside and formed an alternative power base, I suppose. So is that one reason why the Japanese think, well, this place is really fragmented and divided, we can just waltz in and take it all? One phrase that was used by a Japanese commentator, admittedly one who had a vested interest in trying to split China up, was that China at that time, the 1930s, was not a country, it was a geographical expression. Now, I think that's too strong. But the way in which I try
临近1937年，军阀割据的情况并没有那么严重，但我这种想法对吗？中国依然相当分裂，不是吗？所以你有蒋介石和国民党。你还有毛泽东和已经完成了长征的共产党人。所以他们算是进入了农村，建立了另一个权力基地，我想。那么，这也是日本人认为“这个地方真的很破碎和分裂，我们可以直接大摇大摆进去占领一切”的原因之一吗？日本评论员曾使用过的一个词——诚然，这个人有着试图分裂中国的既得利益——是当时的中国，即20世纪30年代，不是一个国家，而是一个地理上的表达。现在，我认为这太绝对了。但我试图
and explain perhaps the view from Nanjing, Chiang Kai-shek's capital, and how it looked if you were sitting in his presidential palace, still there, by the way, in the in the center from Nanjing, Chiang Kai-shek's capital, and how it looked if you were sitting in his presidential palace, still there, by the way, in the center of Nanjing, you might think of it as a sort of nerve center in which the further you get away from Nanjing, the less power the national government of China has. So if you think about the area, which is actually some of the most prosperous and some of the most culturally significant part of China in the kind of Yangtze Delta area, that's some east central China, you might say. So if you know big cities like Shanghai, Nanjing, provinces like Zhejiang, Jiangsu, those would all be basically part of that heartland. That's really where the Nationalist Revolution had its strongest area of control, along with Guangdong, Canton or Guangzhou, down in the south of China, where it had another beachhead, you might say. And those areas meant that a combination of local elites,
解释南京（蒋介石的首都）的视角，以及如果你坐在他的总统府（顺便说一句，它今天仍然在南京市中心）里，你可能会把它看作是一个神经中枢：你离南京越远，中国国家政府的力量就越弱。所以如果你想想这个地区，它实际上是中国最繁荣、文化上最重要的部分之一，也就是长江三角洲地区，你可以说这是中国的中东部。所以如果你知道像上海、南京这样的大城市，浙江、江苏这样的省份，这些基本上都是核心腹地的一部分。这正是国民革命拥有最强控制力的地区，此外还有中国南方的广东、广州，在那里它拥有另一个可以说是滩头阵地的据点。这些地区意味着，当地精英、
business people, rural landowners, and so forth, who were pretty dedicated to the Nationalist cause, meant that the government was reasonably stable, even though it had various things that were very problematic. For instance, it didn't have a very, very strong regular tax income. And a lot of that was dependent on an institution called the Maritime Customs Service, which essentially was, again, as many things were at this time, was run by a bunch of Brits. It was actually founded by an Ulsterman called Sir Robert Hart, who had come from Portadown and ended up in the service of China. But even though he died in 1911, the customs remained as a sort of reliable stream of income for the recognized Chinese government. But the further you got away from Nanjing, the further you find yourself into
商界人士、农村地主等的组合，对国民党事业相当忠诚，这意味着政府相当稳定，尽管它存在各种非常具争议的问题。例如，它没有非常非常强大的常规税收收入。其中很大一部分依赖于一个叫做海关总税务司的机构，本质上，和当时许多事情一样，它是由一帮英国人管理的。它实际上是由一个来自波塔当的阿尔斯特人罗伯特·哈特爵士创立的，他来到中国并为中国服务。但尽管他在1911年去世，海关仍然是被承认的中国政府可靠的收入来源。然而，你离南京越远，你就会发现自己身处
areas where essentially other Chinese military leaders might pay nominal allegiance to Chiang Kai-shek's nationalist government, but in practice, did whatever the heck they wanted. So Sichuan down in the southwest, Manchuria before the Japanese conquest, Dongbei, the northeast, which was under the control of a younger warlord called the Young Marshal, or indeed large parts of northeast central China, Shanxi province, ruled by an extremely, in some ways quite progressive warlord, Yan Xishan, very much against things like foot binding, but a man who kept his own army very, very close to hand to make sure that Chiang Kai-shek or any other ruler couldn't simply tell him what to do. So Chiang Kai-shek was doing a combination of bribery, coercion and conquest out that one of the many reasons why China became destabilized in the war years was that they had to flee that cultural heartland in Nanjing and around and instead make their way to another part of China, the southwest, that is the center of gravity, cultural, economic, financial. And would it be fair to say that you've got Beijing in the north, although it's called
这样的地区：基本上其他中国军事领袖可能名义上效忠于蒋介石的国民党政府，但实际上却随心所欲地做他们想做的事。比如西南部的四川，日本征服之前的满洲，东北的“东北”，它受控于一个年轻的军阀——少帅，或者东北中部的大片地区，山西省，由一个在某些方面相当开明的军阀阎锡山统治，他非常反对诸如缠足之类的事情，但却把自己的军队紧紧抓在手里，以确保蒋介石或任何其他统治者不能简单地对他发号施令。因此，蒋介石通过贿赂、胁迫和征服相结合的手段来应对……中国在战争年代变得不稳定的众多原因之一，是他们不得不逃离南京及周边的那个文化腹地，转而前往中国的另一个地方——西南部，那是文化、经济、金融的重心。说北京在北方，虽然它被称为
what, Beiping? Beiping, Northern Peace, because Nanjing had become the capital. And so Beijing, which means northern capital, could not use that name at that time. So that was a former imperial capital. Then you have Nanjing that we've been talking about, which is the nationalist capital. Again, a kind of very ancient Chinese city. So kind of very important in the Chinese psyche. And then you have Shanghai, which is the great kind of commercial port and center. So you have these three ports. You have Chiang Kai-shek head of the nationalist government you've explained you have all these warlords as well you have the communists who at this point are what I mean how how much of a a power are they they are they're kind of sent north central
什么？北平？北平，意为北方的和平，因为南京已经成为了首都。因此，意为北方首都的北京在当时不能使用那个名字。所以那是前帝国首都。然后是你一直在谈论的南京，它是国民政府的首都。同样是一座非常古老的中国城市。因此在中国人的精神中非常重要。然后是上海，它是伟大的商业港口和中心。所以你有这三个港口。你解释了蒋介石作为国民政府首脑，你还有所有这些军阀，你还有共产党人——此时他们是什么？我的意思是，他们有多大力量？他们是……他们被派往中国北部中央，
northern China central northern China Shanxi province basically as you'll have discussed on another episode I know of um of the podcast of the rest is history. They have been sent on the Long March that takes place in 1934 to 35. And essentially, that's Chiang Kai-shek chasing them out of their previous heartland in Jiangxi, which is basically South Central China, and being made to walk thousands of miles up to the northwest of China, to a part of China that's so remote, so difficult to get to that they're safe. It's kind of like being forced out of Islington to go to the Northern Highlands. Well, some of us would love to go to the Northern Highlands. I think it's a fantastic idea, Tom. That sounds lovely, Tom.
中国华北中部、山西省。基本上，正如你将在《历史的余烬》播客的另一集里讨论的那样。他们被派去进行1934年至1935年发生的“长征”。本质上，那是蒋介石把他们赶出他们在江西（基本上是华中南部）的前核心腹地，迫使他们步行数千英里来到中国西北部，来到一个如此偏远、如此难以到达以至于他们很安全的中国地方。这有点像被迫离开伊斯灵顿去北部高地。好吧，我们中的一些人很乐意去北部高地。我认为这是个绝妙的主意，汤姆。听起来很棒，汤姆。
You're not suggesting, call it a difference between the two. But yes, actually, it's like, first of all, being kicked out of Islington, which is when the communists were in Shanghai, then being sent possibly to somewhere like Devon and realizing that they're coming to get you in Devon and then having to take a roundabout route that gets you to the Northern Highlands. But you're traveling via Wales and East Anglia, which is not the most obvious route. OK, right. OK, well, so that sets that up. So that gives us China in early 1937. And then what happens? 1937. And what happens then is in some ways best described by a brief entry from Chiang Kai-shek's diary. And I should say, by the way, here in a word on sources for all these questions, one of the most valuable and relatively recent documents that historians in this period have
你并不是在建议，把这叫作两者之间的区别。但是，是的，实际上，这就像，首先被踢出伊斯灵顿——那是共产党人在上海的时候——然后可能被送到像德文郡那样的地方，却意识到他们正追着你来到德文郡，然后不得不采取一条迂回路线到达北部高地。但你要经由威尔士和东盎格利亚旅行，这不是最明显的路线。好吧，对。好吧，这就奠定了基础。所以这就为我们提供了1937年初的中国。然后发生了什么？1937年。接下来发生的事情，在某些方面最好用蒋介石日记中的一则简短记载来描述。顺便说一句，关于所有这些问题的资料来源，历史学家在这个时期能够获得的、真正自2000年代初以来最宝贵且相对较新的文件之一，
been able to get access to, only since really the early 2000s, is the voluminous diaries of Chiang Kai-shek, China's leader, which he kept all the way from about 1917 up to the early 1970s. So they are a wonderful insight. Obviously, he had to treat it with caution, but they're a wonderful insight into what he and others were thinking around him. And in the summer of 1937, tensions heightened and Chiang Kai-shek and the Chinese leadership were keeping a close eye on what the Japanese were up to. So that is the context for the 7th of July, 1937. And this is essentially a date that in the history of China's war with Japan might be thought of as the moment when, you know, Archduke Ferdinand's car is rounding that corner in Sarajevo. Is he going to go left? Is he going to go right? Oh dear, he goes right. Oh dear, there's a chap called Gavrilo Princip there. And goodness me, what's he got in his hand? I think that story probably is quite well known. In the case of China, what's perhaps less well known is what happens on the outskirts of Beijing,
是中国领导人蒋介石的鸿篇巨制般的日记，他从1917年左右一直写到了20世纪70年代初。因此，它们是一个绝佳的洞察窗口。很明显，人们必须谨慎对待它们，但它们为了解他和周围其他人当时的想法提供了一个极好的窗口。在1937年夏天，紧张局势加剧，蒋介石和中国领导层一直在密切关注日本人的动向。这就是1937年7月7日这一天的背景。这本质上是中国抗日历史上可以被视为这样一个时刻的日期：你知道，大公斐迪南的车正在萨拉热窝拐那个弯。他是向左走，还是向右走？哦天哪，他向右走。哦天哪，那里有个叫加夫里洛·普林西普的家伙。天哪，他手里拿的是什么？我想那个故事大概广为人知。就中国而言，或许不那么广为人知的是7月7日晚在北京郊外，
this little village called Wanping on the evening of 7th of July. What happens is that one of those locally garrisoned Japanese troop deployments that I've mentioned, the ones that have been put there through imperial powers, they're on sovereign Chinese territory, but they're allowed to be there. They're taking roll call and a couple of the soldiers don't answer roll call and um their offer their commanding officer gets extremely worried stroke angry about this and thinks that what's happened is that local chinese warlord troops must have basically knocked a couple of them off for sport and he's not having any of it um it the missing soldiers actually do turn up the next morning and i think a slightly possibly embellished version of the story, but it may have something to it is that basically they popped off to have a pee. And they realized they'd missed roll call, they get into trouble. So they didn't actually report themselves back. So you might say that two soldierly bladders may have had something to do with the outbreak of World War II in China. But by that stage, things were beginning to spiral out of
这个名叫宛平的小村庄发生了什么。发生的事情是，我提到过的那支驻扎在那里的当地日本军队之一——那些通过帝国强权安插在那里的军队，他们在中国的主权领土上，但被允许驻扎在那里——正在点名，有两名士兵没有喊“到”，他们的指挥官对此感到非常担忧乃至愤怒，并认为发生的事情一定是当地中国军阀军队为了好玩干掉了其中几名士兵，他绝不罢休。失踪的士兵实际上在第二天早上就出现了，我想这是一个略带美化色彩的版本，尽管它可能有些根据，那就是他们其实是跑去撒尿了。他们意识到自己错过了点名，会惹上麻烦。所以他们实际上没有自己报告归队。因此，你可能会说，两个士兵的膀胱可能与中国抗日战争的爆发有某种关系。但在那个阶段，事情开始失控，因为基本上在向上报告后，当地日军说：我们失去了这些士兵，中国人一定干的。中国人说这与我们无关。本质上，双方发生了对抗，日本指挥官随后表示：“好吧，你知道，我们绝不接受这个。我们要求对北京这部分的大部分领土——包括铁路枢纽——拥有更多控制权。”
control because essentially having reported up, the local Japanese troops said, we've lost these troops. Chinese must have done it. Chinese said it has nothing to do with us. And essentially, a confrontation occurred between the two sides in which the Japanese commanders then say, well, you know, we're not having any of this. And we demand much more control over much of the territory in this part of Beijing, including the railway junctions. And this is a really, really important element because whoever controls the railways can control freight, can control the transport of troops, and of course, can control communications,
这是一个非常非常重要的元素，因为谁控制了铁路，谁就能控制货运，控制军队的运输，当然，广义上讲，还能控制中国北方那一地区的通讯。因此，这达到了这样一个地步：它基本上被紧急上报给国民政府，即身在南京的蒋介石。我们该怎么办？在那之前，在过去的几年里，甚至在侵占满洲之后，蒋介石基本上奉行的是公开的不抵抗政策。在幕后，他以各种方式袭扰日本人，但公开地说，我们不会被卷入冲突。这不是解决之道，因为他知道这会有多具毁灭性。他在当天或次日的日记中写道：这是与日本人对抗的时刻吗？
you know, broadly speaking, in that part of northern China. And so this reached a point where essentially it was flashed up to the national government, Chiang Kai-shek down in Nanjing. What are we going to do? And up to that point, for the previous few years, even after the invasion of Manchuria, Chiang Kai-shek had essentially operated a policy of public non-resistance. Behind the scenes, he was sort of harrying the Japanese in various ways, but publicly he was saying, we're not going to get pulled into a conflict. That's not the way to go because he knew how devastating it could be. And in his diary for that or the day after, he writes, is this the moment for confrontation with the Japanese?
这是转折点吗？所以他能看到，这一刻或许正是某种真正毁灭性事件即将发生的时刻。事实上，他身边的人、各种顾问都说：看，我们在中国根本没有足够的力量去真正对抗日本人。是的，我们有一支庞大的军队，但它们是由军阀控制的。他们没有经过良好训练。这在很大程度上是一个农业社会。日本军队高度机械化。我们根本赢不了这场战争。蒋介石考虑了这一切，然后说：不，这一次，在经历了所有的挑衅之后，在经历了满洲事件之后，在经历了虽小但仍然非常令人担忧的事件、最后是现在这个对领土的新要求之后，在1937年，
Is this the turning point? So he can see that this moment is maybe the moment at which something really devastating is going to happen. And he had people around him, actually, various advisors said, look, we're just not strong enough in China to actually fight the Japanese. Yes, we have a large army, but it's controlled by warlords. They're not well trained. It's largely agrarian society. The Japanese army is heavily mechanized. We just can't win this war. And Chiang Kai-shek thinks about it and says, no, this time, after all the provocations, after Manchuria, after smaller, but still very worrying incidents, and finally now this new demand for territory, in 1937,
7月，他说，我们必须反击。通过做出这个决定并召开基本上做出这一决定的战争委员会，他开启了冲突，这不再是北京城外这些士兵之间的一场非常局部的摩擦，而是演变成了日本帝国与中华民国之间的民族国家战争。这就是两国之间冲突的开始。所以拉纳，有些人可能会觉得这有违直觉，因为我们对中日战争的普遍看法是日本对中国的侵略战争。但在某种程度上，你是说蒋介石有意识地、刻意地选择接受卢沟桥事变的挑衅。他本可以不予理睬的。
in July, he says, we have to push back. And by making that decision and by holding a war council, which essentially takes the decision, he opens up the conflict, which moves from being a very local skirmish between these soldiers just outside Beijing, to becoming a war of nation states between the Japanese Empire and the Republic of China. And that is the beginning of the conflict between the two. So Rana, some people may find that counterintuitive, because the common way that we think about the Sino-Japanese War is a war of Japanese aggression against China. But in a way, you're saying that Chiang Kai-shek consciously, deliberately, chooses to accept this provocation of the Marco Polo Bridge. And he could have passed it up.
那么，是否存在这样一种替代现实：他没有理睬它，战争也没有爆发？或者你认为战争有点像关于第一次世界大战的争论，实际上就是萨拉热窝的平行事件？战争无论如何都是不可避免的要到来吗？是的，这是一个非常好的平行事件。同样，我想人们也可以问这样一个问题：对于1939年9月3日，内维尔·张伯伦是否本可以找到一种方法来摆脱对波兰的保证？或者到那个阶段这可能很困难。选择总是存在的。它们并不总是正确的选择，但它们必须做出。我认为
And is there an alternative reality, as it were, in which he does pass it up and the war doesn't break out? Or do you think war was a bit like the argument about the First World War, actually, the Sarajevo parallel? Was war coming inevitably anyway? Yes, it's a very good parallel. And again, one could, I suppose, ask the question, actually, for 3rd of September 39, you know, could Neville Chamberlain have found a way to perhaps get out of the Polish guarantee? Or that probably would have been difficult by that stage. There are always choices. They're not always the right choices, but they have to be made. I think
蒋介石当然认为战争显然正在到来。如果当时不来，很快也会到来。顾问们，像学者蒋文林这样经验丰富、深思熟虑、懂中国历史的人，当时在说（我想他说过大概到1940年左右）——我们需要这么长时间来重新武装。当然，欧洲也有关于重新武装的类似争论。问题在于，到这个阶段，我认为非常明显的是——而且日本人自己也没有表现出任何相反的迹象——其目标基本上是征服中国的大部分地区，也许不是作为正式的殖民地化，而是扩大中国（也就是日本）本已非常非常巨大的控制量。如果他们夺取了那个铁路枢纽，而那是37年7月那个特定决定的核心所在，那么基本上，你就做出了一个将中国北方拱手让给日本整整一代人的决定。包括北京。整整一代人的北京。现在，那不是他的首都，但在文化上，
that Chiang Kai-shek certainly thought that the war was clearly coming. And if it didn't come then, it would come very soon. And the advisors, people like the academic Jiang Wenlin, you know, very experienced and thoughtful guy who knew his Chinese history, was saying, you know, give it till, I think he said till about 1940, something like that. That's how long we'll need to rearm. And of course, there are similar arguments about rearmament in Europe as well. The problem is that by this stage, I think it was eminently clear, and certainly the Japanese themselves gave no indication otherwise, that the aim was essentially conquest of large parts of China, maybe not as formal colonization, but expanding the already very, very significant amount of control that China, so Japan had. And if they'd taken that railway junction, which was at the heart of the particular decision in July of 37, then essentially you do have a decision that you are handing over North China to Japan for a generation. Including Beijing. Including Beijing for a generation. Now, that's not where his capital was, but culturally,
将北京交还给日本人将是一个具有极深象征意义和奇耻大辱的时刻。拉纳，蒋介石开战的决定，基本上是这样。共产党人对此态度如何？他们是这其中的同谋吗？共产党人起初并不太清楚发生了什么，因为当然，他们将一切都视为更广泛的帝国主义阴谋的一部分。当然，他们也在接受斯大林的指示。但与此同时，他们也被要求表现得最好。我只需要简单回顾一下斯大林的指示。但与此同时，他们也被表现得很好。我只需要简单回顾一下几个月的情况。
handing over Beijing to the Japanese would have been a deeply symbolic and deeply humiliating moment. And Rana, Cankocek's decision to go to war, basically. Yes. What is the attitude of the communists to this? And are they complicit in it? The communists at first aren't quite sure what's going on, because of course, they regard everything as being part of a wider imperialist conspiracy. And of course, they're getting instructions from Stalin. But at the same time, they've also been put on their best behavior. And I just need to go back briefly for a couple from Stalin. But at the same time, they've also been put on their best behavior. And I just need to go back briefly for a couple of months.
在上一年的年底，即1936年12月，出现了一些情况，蒋介石被几个军阀短暂绑架。一个是满洲少帅，另一个是一个叫杨虎城的男子。这两位军阀基本上在西北中国的西安城绑架了他，将他关在一栋别墅里。我的意思是，当这个人意识到自己即将被绑架时，慌乱中跑上山坡，他的假牙显然掉在了山坡上，不得不被捡起来清洗干净，然后重新塞回嘴里。这些军阀基本上是在与共产党人合作，后者也极力想把蒋介石控制在手中。当听到他被绑架的消息时，毛泽东和其他人觉得：好吧，干掉这家伙吧，审判他并因他犯下的反中国人民罪行而枪决他。
Right at the end of the previous year, in December 1936, circumstances emerged in which Chiang Kai-shek is kidnapped briefly by a couple of warlords. One was the young marshal of Manchuria, another one, a man called Yang Ho-chung. And these two warlords basically kidnap him in the city of xi'an in uh northwestern china hold him in a villa uh i mean you know the man when he sort of realized he was about to be kidnapped sort of caught running up a hill his false teeth had apparently fallen out onto the the hillside and had to be picked up and clean for put back in being put back in his mouth and these warlords are basically in uh collaboration with the communists who were also very keen to get chiang Kai-shek under their control. And when the news came in that he'd been kidnapped, the communists, Mao and others were like, well, let's kill the guy, you know, give him a trial and shoot him for his crimes against the Chinese people.
然后基本上一个非常大的人物介入了。那个人就是约瑟夫·斯大林，他对共产党人说“不”。你们不能这么做。原因很简单。考虑到我们在这里讨论的是什么时间，这是1936-37年。苏联的红军正在经历巨大的清洗，而且非常非常——你知道的——它还没有达到全盛状态。斯大林非常担心——他也确实应该担心——德国在西线和日本在东线发动攻击的可能性。应对其中一个就已经够受的了。
And then basically a very big name steps in. And that guy is Joseph Stalin, who says no to the communists. You're not going to do this. And the reason is very simple. Bearing in mind what time we're talking about here, this is 1936-37. The Red Army in the Soviet Union is undergoing huge purges and it's very, very, you know, it's not at its full strength. Stalin is desperately worried as well he should be about the possibility of an attack from Germany on the western side and Japan on the east. One of those is enough to deal with.
两个对于苏联来说将是绝对致命的。他最不需要的就是蒋介石——在这个阶段全国层面上中国唯一可靠的领导人——被干掉。谁来接替？好吧，也许是我们之前提到过的汪精卫，我们提到过他比蒋介石更亲日，至少在公众印象中是这样。
Two would be absolutely deadly for the Soviet Union. The last thing he needs is basically Chiang Kai-shek, who's the only credible leader that China has at a national level at this stage, being knocked off. And who takes over? Well, maybe Wang Jingwei, who we mentioned before, who we mentioned is much more pro-Japanese than Chiang Kai-shek, at least in public perception.
所以斯大林会允许中国共产党人干掉一个以反对外部势力（尤其是日本势力入侵）而闻名的领导人，转而放任一个可能更容易接受这一点的中国领导人吗？当然，他不会这么做。所以在那个阶段，中国共产党人知道他们无法将蒋介石从他的宝座上赶下来。但当1937年7月战争真正爆发时，他们非常非常快地被纳入了以抗日民族统一战线形式进行的讨论中。那是当时使用的词汇。国民党人和共产党人举行了一次会议。他们派出了他们的一些最高领导人，基本上达成了一项协议。它以这样或那样的形式贯穿了整个第二次世界大战，那就是在国家危机时期，
So is Stalin going to allow the Chinese communists to kill a leader who is well known for his opposition to outside forces, especially the Japanese, coming in and instead let in a Chinese leader who might be much more amenable to that? Of course, he's not going to do that. So by that stage, the Chinese communists know that they're not going to be in a position to knock Chiang Kai-shek off his perch. But when the war actually breaks out in July 1937, they're brought into discussions very, very quickly in a united front. That's the phrase that's used at the time. The nationalists and the communists have a meeting. They send some of their top leaders and essentially a deal is done. It lasts through in one form or another through the whole of the Second World War, which is that during the time of national crisis,
面对日本的侵略，中国的国民党人和共产党人，尽管他们彼此痛恨、水火不容，也将勉强地合作共同反对日本人。然后，当对日战争结束后，我们再看之后会发生什么。好吧。所以北京沦陷了。上海，上海发生了什么？北京在1937年夏天沦陷了，尽管它可能也不是很容易防守。我的意思是，几周内就沦陷了，拉纳。非同寻常。这么大的一座城市。我的意思是，在几周内就消失了。那主要是因为中央国民党正规军的控制，因为基本上它是由各种人的军队防守的，包括宋哲元和其他当地军阀——当我们说军阀军队时，你知道，我们在这里谈论的不是日本在这个阶段设法组建的那种训练有素、随时准备投入战场的士兵，我们谈论的是好啦，被从农村抓来的农家子弟，
the invasion by Japan, China's nationalists and communists, much that they hate each other, daggers drawn and all of that, will uneasily work together to oppose the Japanese. And then when the war against Japan is over, then we see what happens after that. Yeah. Okay. So Beijing falls. Shanghai, what happens in Shanghai? Beijing falls in summer of 1937, although it probably wasn't very easily defensible either. I mean, it fell within weeks, Prana. Extraordinary. Such a huge city. I mean, just gone within a couple of weeks. that was primarily under nationalist central army control uh because essentially it was defended by troops of various people including sung joe yuan and other local warlords who when we say warlord armies you know we're not here talking about the kind of superbly trained battlefield ready um soldiers that japan had managed to put together by the stage we're talking about okay peasant boys
通常很不情愿待在那里。是的，那些军队没能守住北京。上海则不同。上海是蒋介石选择死守的地方。所以我提到战争是在中国北方的北京周边爆发的。但蒋介石决定，好吧，如果战争开始了，那么我们需要开辟第二条战线。第二条战线于1937年8月在中国东海岸更南方的伟大港口城市上海迅速开辟。蒋介石这样做有几个原因。一个是世界各地的记者都在那里。我的意思是，你在本播客的开头提到过他、伊舍伍德和奥登，他们于1937-38年一起在中国，写了一本名为《走向战争的旅程》的精彩书籍，讲述了他们
brought out of the countryside often not very keen to be there. And yes, those troops were not able to hold Beijing. Shanghai was different. And Shanghai was where Chiang Kai-shek chose to make a stand. So I mentioned the war opened in northern China around Beijing. But Chiang Kai-shek decided, well, if the war's beginning, then we need to open up a second front. And the second front was opened up rapidly in August 1937 in the great port city of Shanghai, much further to the south on the eastern coast of China. And Chiang Kai-shek did it for a couple of reasons. One is that the world's press was there. I mean, you started this podcast with that he and Isherwood and Auden, who were there together in China in 1937-38, wrote a wonderful book called Journey to a War, which is about their
当时在中国经历。因此，来自西方的形形色色的人都在注视着发生的事情。奥登，伟大的战地摄影师罗伯特·卡帕，当时在中国拍下了他的一些最精美的照片。许多人直接从已经在那个阶段肆虐了一年的西班牙战争来到这里。这大概对蒋介石保持中国在国际上的视线至关重要。在公众视野中。当时，在华人和其他人心中，
experiences in China from that time. So all sorts of people from the West were watching what was happening. Auden, the great war photographer Robert Capa, took some of his finest photos in China at that time. Many people came straight from the war in Spain, which had already been raging for a year at that stage. And this is presumably really important for Chiang to keep China in the global eye. In the public view. At that time, in the mind of the Chinese and others,
西班牙内战和中国抗日战争被视为进步硬币的两面。奥登和伊舍伍德这样的人也倾向于这样认为。他们明确表示他们去过西班牙，然后又来到了中国。那时人们的心中，这两者是联系在一起的，而在现在，这种说法已经不那么常见了。所以宣传是一个原因。但另一个原因与军队训练有关。
the Spanish Civil War and the Chinese war against Japan were regarded as two sides of the progressive coin. And people like Auden and Isherwood tend to think so as well. They were explicit about the fact that they've been in Spain and then in China. The two went together in minds then, in then where it isn't so commonly heard now. So the publicity is one reason. But another reason is to do with troop training.
西班牙内战和中国抗日战争被视为进步硬币的两面。奥登和伊舍伍德等人也倾向于这么认为。他们明确表示，他们曾去过西班牙，然后又去过中国。当时人们的心态将这两者联系在一起，而这在现在已经不那么常见了。因此，宣传是一个原因。但另一个原因与军队训练有关。
The best troops that China had, Chiang Kai-shek's finest troops, were essentially stationed in and around Shanghai. And they had been trained by actually some of the best German commanders, Hans von Sigt and then Alexander von Falkenhausen, who had been brought in as German military advisors to Chiang Kai-shek's armies in the 1930s. And the historian Hans van der Ven has written in great detail about the amazing detail of how these troops were actually retrained. So China did have its own core of modernized troops, but they were a relatively very small number of the millions who were recruited overall. And Chiang, I think, would have hoped that they would have been able to hold Shanghai for as long as possible. And indeed, they did hold out for about three months in Shanghai. But Shanghai turned into a city that was a battlefield. Trenches were literally dug in the streets of Shanghai, not in the French concession and not in that international settlement that we mentioned earlier, because those areas were
中国当时拥有的最精锐部队、蒋介石最好的军队，基本上都驻扎在上海及其周边地区。这些部队实际上是由一些最优秀的德国指挥官训练出来的，先是汉斯·冯·塞克特，然后是亚历山大·冯·法肯豪森，他们在20世纪30年代作为德国军事顾问被引入蒋介石的军队。历史学家方德万曾详细撰文描述了这些军队如何被重新训练的惊人细节。因此，中国确实拥有自己的现代化核心部队，但在总共征召的数百万军队中，他们的数量相对非常少。而且我认为，蒋介石本来希望他们能够尽可能长时间地守住上海。事实上，他们在上海确实坚持了大约三个月。但上海变成了一座战场城市。上海的街道上真的挖了战壕，但没有挖在法租界，也没有挖在我们前面提到过的那个公共租界，因为这些地区是
neutral, because of course, they were run by foreigners, they weren't under Chinese sovereignty. But you could look from your tea time terrace at the Cathay Hotel, in the international settlement, almost, or the rooftop anyway, and see the fighting going on just across the city border in the Chinese controlled area, which in the words of Orden looked like a moonscapecape because it was being so heavily bombed. And although the more than 100,000 Chinese troops who were fighting there fought very, very valiantly, commemorated actually in a movie that was a big hit in China and briefly released in the UK a couple of years ago called The 800, which is about the last stand of some of those Chinese soldiers in a warehouse on the riverbank of Shanghai. Eventually, by November of 1937,
中立的，因为它们当然是由外国人管理的，不属于中国主权。但是你可以从公共租界内华懋饭店的下午茶露台上，或者至少从屋顶上望过去，看到战斗就在城市边界对面的中国控制区进行。在奥登看来，那里看起来就像一个月球表面，因为它遭到了如此猛烈的轰炸。尽管在那里战斗的十多万中国军队打得非常非常英勇——几年前在中国大热并在英国短暂上映的一部名为《八佰》的电影实际上就是在纪念这件事，这部电影讲述了部分中国士兵在上海河畔的一座仓库里进行最后坚守的故事——最终，到1937年11月，
they were defeated, many of them had been killed, and the Chinese troops as a whole were ordered to retreat from Shanghai because it was simply no longer defensible. But it became the first really public major battle of the Chinese war against Japan. And so Shanghai falls to Japanese takeover. That's right. In November 1937, Shanghai is captured by the Japanese. Again, not the foreign-controlled areas
他们被打败了，许多人阵亡，中国军队总体上奉命撤出上海，因为这里实在已经无法防守。但它成为了中国对日战争中第一场真正公开的重大战役。因此上海沦陷于日本之手。没错。1937年11月，上海被日本人攻占。同样，不是那些外资控制的地区，
which don't fall until Pearl Harbor, but essentially by that stage, by the end of 1937, beginning of 1938, Shanghai and much of the area around it is in Japanese hands. And the Chinese nationalists, Chiang Kai-shek and his government and much of the army have shipped downriver 800 miles to the southwestern city of Chongqing,
这些地区直到珍珠港事件爆发才沦陷，但基本上到了那个阶段，即1937年底到1938年初，上海及其周边的大部分地区都落入了日本人手中。中国国民党人、蒋介石及其政府以及大部分军队已经顺江而下800英里，撤到了西南部城市重庆，
known in the West at that time often as Chongqing, which became the temporary wartime capital of China from 1937 all the way up to 1946. And the war, from their point of view, moves inland. So Rana, that seems like the perfect place to break. Because of course, next in their sights is the capital, isn't it? Nanjing. And many of our listeners will know that things don't unfold well for the people in Nanjing. But we will come back to that next time in our next episode. So thank you very much, Rana, and we'll see you all next time.
在西方当时通常被称为Chungking，它成为了中国从1937年一直到1946年的战时临时首都。从他们的角度来看，战争向内陆转移了。那么，拉娜，这似乎是一个完美的暂停切入点。因为当然，他们下一个目标就是首都，不是吗？南京。我们的许多听众都知道，南京人民的遭遇并不好。但我们将在下一次的节目中再来探讨这一点。所以非常感谢拉娜，我们下次节目再见。
Look forward to that. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
期待那期节目。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听并进入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们还将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和优先购买现场门票的权利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。